il est 13h30 dans cette courbe à la
sortie de gilly-sur-loire un bus et un
poids-lourd s'apprête à se croiser vu la
chanson veut dire d'être assise dans le
fond du bus complètement en font donc
j'étais sur mon téléphone et au moment
où l'horreur je reverrai augmenter les
phones je lève la tête on arrive dans un
virage un peu serré quand même pour de
gros poids lourds et j'ai vu la remorque
qui a détaché du camion et j'ai vu
percuté le bus tout de suite et le choc
le chauffeur gravement blessé est évacué
a dit jean par hélicoptère dans le bus
une trentaine de salariés de
l'entreprise
ftv iveco de bourbon lancy ils
rentraient chez eux après leur journée
de travail
ils ont été pris en charge sur les lieux
mêmes de l'accident
les blessés légers ont d'abord été
soigné sur place et l'actuellement un
poste médical avancé qui est la salle
des fêtes de la commune de saint-aubin
qui a été activée de façon à ce qu'une
nouveau diagnostic soit porté sur l'état
de santé de ces personnes ils soient
évacués et on ouvre également une
cellule psychologique est parti à
l'hôpital de paray une jambe je crois de
casser les autres dont le cervicales
puis tout le monde le visage mon léger
ou mai puis voilà une chaussée étroite
et glissante
une chose est sûre 2 véhicule de ce
gabarit ne pouvait se croiser ici en
toute sécurité qu'en roulant très
lentement
ça n'a peut-être pas été le cas l'
enquête le dira